Oh wait, you're listening. Okay.
You are listening to radio lab radio from W N Y.
S. T. Yep. Hey,
I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich, Radiolab and you know,
here we are in this moment where we're about to get started with another
election cycle, another Iowa and other New Hampshire, Carolina, all of that.
And this is the time when we reporters decide, Whoa,
we're going to have to tell you some stuff and you're going to have to decide
what matters to you. And, uh, the story that we're gonna tell them.
This podcast is about a moment, a shockingly recent moment.
That's how I felt when I first heard this story. A moment of when,
what reporters decide to tell on what people decide to value really changed.
So we're going to take you back to an evening in 1987,
Tom Fiedler, a split Hickle reporter for the Miami Herald.
It's late at night and he's in his office.
I'm at my desk and just in fact packing up to go home.
My phone rang and I'm thinking, oh, it's probably my wife.
And she's wondering why I haven't left yet. I said, all right, I'll pick it up.
But when he picked up the phone, turned out this, uh,
it turned out it was not a voice.
He recognized it was a woman's voice maybe in her late twenties.
And she said to him, I have something you need to know.
It was a tip about one of the most powerful and charismatic men in American
politics, former senator Gary Hart,
who at the time was not only the most likely candidate to become the Democratic
nominee,
he was very possibly going to be the next president of the United States.
Her words to me, whore,
Gary Hart is having an affair with one of my best friends.
And she told him, basically I can prove it. And uh, you know, I,
I was a rather I guess, uh, uh, dumps truck
[inaudible]
any thought on our, what do we do now if you're of a certain age,
you probably remember this story. You probably know what happens next.
But even if you've never heard of Gary Hart,
you still probably know the outline of this story. The accusation
[inaudible] Elliott Spit John Edward. Then the denial.
I did not have sexual relations with that woman. And then after that,
the whole wall, the wall media thing and thing scan, scan,
which just goes on and on and on until you want to take your head off your
shoulders, put it on the sidewalk and beat it with a baseball bat.
But the thing that's easy to forget is that it wasn't always like this.
No
was the first to walk into this vortex of social forces.
And after that,
the rules of political journalism and politics change almost immediately,
by the way, is mat by national political columnist for Yahoo News.
He wrote a book about this incident, which he called all the truth is out.
And in that book he makes the argument
that this is the moment Gary Hart,
1987 when political journalism slid off the rails,
or you would argue when it finally got serious. Well, you know, it was fun
back a minute. Cause I think, I think the context is important.
1984 heart kind of comes from nowhere.
It's a whole new ballgame in the race for the Democratic presidential nomination
runs for president dorms.
New Hampshire Senator Gary Hart is on his way to a clear cut victory over
Walter Mondale Mondale
there and becomes a political celebrity that's country,
cannot stand for more years of
Reaganomics for the Rep. Very
hard. Gary Hart, the Senator From Colorado, Gary Hart,
I'm a Democrat and proud of it. Part was this tall, good looking democrat.
He's got great wavy hair. I mean dashing, handsome,
charismatic and young. This is Leslie stall, CBS.
She's covered politics for 40 years now. Works for 60 minutes.
He was cool and smart women liked him too.
He's an anti Orthodox Democrat, very liberal
oral anti nukes is sort of the Bill Clinton before Bill Clinton.
He doesn't get the Democratic nomination in 1984 Walter Mondale does by a nose,
but when Mondale gets crushed by Ronald Reagan,
Hart is immediately presumed to be the next nominee of the party at a time when
these things were more obvious. So fast forward to 1987
like it or not, campaign 88 is underway and the leading contender, front runner,
Gary Hart in New Hampshire, he's, he's winning.
He's running double digits higher than any Democrat and he's projected to beat
George Bush, the Republican front runner, ex president of the United States.
Very hard.
It felt like, look, this is a guy who is changing politics,
who is unafraid to speak the truth,
who is willing to be really clear about what he wants to do.
That's Kevin Sweeney.
He was heart's press secretary in 1987 he joined the campaign a just a few years
out of college, 23. I'm idealistic. The first time we, um, we really met,
he, I was wearing a neck tie with pictures of Lincoln and Washington on it.
And Hart said, that's the ugliest neck tie I've ever seen in my life,
so that my mother made it and he said, I apologize. Well,
that's a good beginning. Yeah, I knew pretty early I wanted to work for a heart.
You remember why? Um, he was really liberal on social issues at the time.
Unafraid to be specific or take a stand. I mean, he said heart, uh,
place an extraordinary amount of emphasis on not just winning the campaign,
but what would they do when they gotten office? He commanded that attitude.
So they wrote out all these position papers on foreign policy, energy,
international trade,
the budget even what would his relationship with Gorbachev be?
There was something about heart and something about the,
what happened on the campaign where it did feel like the kind of campaign that I
haven't seen since.
And when does the subject of what goes on below the belt come up, if at all? Um,
we'll, they were rumors, definitely rumors sign.
There are a lot of whispers about his personal life and a lot of speculation.
He's been married to his, uh, college sweetheart Lee for a very long time.
They've been separated twice, no long separations. And during those separations,
he's dated openly in Washington.
So it's a well known a fact of life in Washington where he is a central figure
and has a lot of friends in the press corps that he's dated, uh,
that he's dated people for extended periods of time,
that he and his wife have a troubled marriage, uh, together and not together.
He stayed on Bob Woodward's couch for a little while when she kicked him out at
one point a, nobody wrote about that.
And the reason they didn't write about it was because of a very old,
very well established convention. I mean, look,
go back to the 20th century. Franklin Roosevelt, Lyndon Johnson,
Dwight Eisenhower, uh, you know, heroes towering figures,
their personal lives simply were not in play. Take for example, JFK.
Leslie stall says that when the press was covering him,
vast numbers of reporters knew that John Kennedy was cheating on his wife.
That was no secret,
but we wouldn't have dreamed of printing that even if the whispers were loud
enough to spread around the country. It just wasn't done is the thought. Hey,
I could, nobody does that. So I, you know, forget about it. Or, Hey,
that has nothing to do with with statecraft. I think the feeling was that,
so what, you know,
we all get to have a zone of privacy and the assumption was that, uh,
what happened in your private zone behind closed doors had nothing to do with
whether you were going to be a good president or not.
I mean there are certain ethics and certain standards,
I guess this is the world that heart still thinks he's living in it.
As long as it doesn't burst into public view, it won't be a story.
But Matt by says that world was actually changing because of a political
earthquake that had happened just over a decade before talking about the
Watergate,
breaking burglarizing and bugging Democratic headquarters in Washington that
isn't big first knocked out brick in that wall.
Five people have been arrested and charged with breaking into the headquarters
of the Democratic National Committee. You know,
arguably the biggest scandal in White House history.
You had Nixon tapping phone lines, compiling enemy lists, stairwell,
and for the reporters covering Nixon, it really is an embarrassment.
[inaudible].
You had an entire White House press corps,
Political Press Corp Campaign Press Corps who had followed this man,
Richard Nixon for decades and somehow either missed the fact or failed to report
the fact that he had some significant psychological issues and was paranoid,
uh, and and could be corrupted.
I think there was a sense that we let the public down,
Leslie Stall Remembers it this way. The regular White House press reporters,
they should have been digging, chipping away, chipping away,
chipping away. They should have been looking behind the curtain.
And so right after Watergate
reporters became tougher saying, okay,
we have to be skeptical about everything. And in particular the character issue,
meaning suddenly your makeup, your personal behavior,
who you are in your private moments matters a whole hell of a lot for the kind
of president you can be and whether or not we can trust you as a public leader.
[inaudible]
parts character is the subject tonight of our weekend journal. One,
Americans choose precedents.
Personal character traits are important in this day and age. Candidates,
personal lives are getting a great deal of scrutiny. I remember
there was a bit of a shift in the kinds of reporters who were covering national
politics.
They had a different orientation and they were really interested in the
character question. That's Kevin Sweeney again.
He says he was initially frustrated by reporters,
strange obsession with things that were not really issues,
important issues in the campaign like age.
There was some confusion about heart's age.
The fact that he changed the family name, uh,
his signature changed at a certain point in his life.
He says when those stories initially popped up,
I thought it was a false set of issues. I didn't really take it seriously.
But then when it came to the rumors, yeah.
Of quote womanizing or marital infidelity,
he felt like he needed to talk to Gary Hart.
Yeah, I did say if anything is happening, it needs to stop. I mean, this can't,
whatever it is. I mean, I, I, and he said, you know, nothing is happening.
And he shot back and said they have no right to cover that. That's ridiculous.
It's not an issue that, you know, why is that an issue? That's not their job.
And I kept pushing back saying, I don't,
I don't actually care what their job is. I don't,
I don't care what you think their job is. This is the new context that exists.
Now. I don't know why or how, but the rules have changed.
The rules have changed.
[inaudible]
so, uh, uh, it, you know, it was, it,
this brings us back to Tom Fiedler at the Miami Herald.
He was covering Gary Hart, going with him to all the stops in Iowa,
New Hampshire and so forth.
And it seemed like at every stop along the way,
someone, some reporter would raise her his hand and would say,
what about the rumors of his womanizing?
And Tom says that he would see reporters asking all these questions and he,
he was a little bit troubled. So on April 27th, 1987,
he wrote a column asking the question,
is it ethical for journalists to be even raising this kind of a,
of a question?
And I really came down to the conclusion that unless the a media,
unless the reporters involved had actual proof that um,
this was a problem, that he was a womanizer. We just shouldn't be printing.
That column runs on a Monday morning.
That night he gets the call of voice on the other side,
says Gary Hart is having an affair with one of my best friends.
He was dumbstruck as we know. I told her that, uh,
my position had to be that I couldn't believe what she had to say unless there
was proof. And um, finally she said,
my friend is going to fly up to Washington next weekend and she's going to spend
the weekend with Senator Hart. She said,
so all you have to do is buy a ticket on that plane.
And I thought, well, would that be ethically okay?
What is inbounds and what is out of it?
Bounds. I mean, character was this new obsession of political journalism.
But according to Matt by,
no one had taken that character question into a candidates bedroom.
That was new.
But Feedly thought, well, no, no, no, no, this, this is inbound.
Because Gary Hart was publicly denying that he had been carrying on affairs
with, with anyone in particular. It'd be clear,
oftentimes when Gary Hart was asked about these rumors of an affair,
he's never asked directly just about the rumors. He'd say something like this,
it's no one else's business. Now why is it not anyone else's business?
Because it isn't no,
but hasn't been the business of the American public for 200 years.
And it isn't today. He'd say something like that.
But Fiedler says a couple of times when he's asked,
he did say something that amounted to a no,
such as if there was any truth to these allegations,
it would have come out long before the kinds of answers that were non denials,
denials. Another phrase that came out of Watergate.
So my view at that point was, um,
if in fact there was proof that he was carrying on an affair privately while
publicly, um, insisting that there really was no base to this,
then that was a relevant issue, relevant to his performance,
just pure future president. Yes. It was a question of integrity.
So Oh,
we thought the only way that we are going to find out if what the caller told us
is true is we've
got to catch him. That's coming up next.
[inaudible]
this would be laser calling from Milwaukee.
Radiolab is supported in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation enhancing public
understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich. This is Radiolab.
Getting back to the story reporter,
Tom Fiedler gets a tip saying that candidate Gary Hart is having an affair and
he thinks to himself, this is inbounds. If it's true, therefore
we've got to catch him.
So it was editor tells a colleague of his Jim McGee to go to the airport telling
him this is what you're going to do.
You're going to look for a woman who looks like a model.
That's how the woman on the phone described her friend.
She's described as a model blonde in her mid twenties and call me back if you
see it. So this Guy Jim races to the airport spots.
This attractive young woman fits the description. Of course,
we later knew was don arise, so he boards the plane, they land in DC,
he follows her out of the airport, do a cab, he runs to another cab,
jumps in at end. He says, follow that cab. Just like in the movies take too.
He loses her for a while,
but then eventually it gets to the house where he thinks Hart and this lady
should be hand.
He's not there more than a few minutes when the front door opens and outcomes.
The young woman on the arm of a very handsome man,
one small problem. Jim had never met Gary Hart.
He had no idea what Gary heart looked like. He said later, he said,
I really couldn't pick Gary Hart out of a lineup.
That's when I really thought we have got to go to Washington and that's what
they do to Harold. Matt by again, they send a team of reporters,
investigative reporters and Fiedler and photographer to Washington.
We arrived Saturday morning. They stake out his townhouse. You know,
I'm thinking, my gosh,
somebody will surely notice that there are four or five of us lurking is
probably the right word.
It's May in one guy's in a Parka to disguise himself and Fiedler who the
candidate knows is in a jogging suit and he's pretending to jog around the
street all day long. I would change clothes a little bit.
Occasionally I would run without the jacket.
Other Times I would just be wearing a tee shirt and shorts.
He'd run around and around and around. It's not how the CIA would do it, uh,
but it's about what you'd expect from a newspaper.
Our quote unquote stakeout went on all day into Saturday night and it got dark
and then front door opens outcomes.
This man and outcomes,
the blonde woman heart walks out with Donna Rice, a sort of arm in arm key.
Quickly realizes something is wrong.
You kind of makes the surveillance. They see him, he sees them,
he turns her back around. They go inside and go back inside the townhouse.
He sends her away through the back door and then he comes back out of the
townhouse, hops in his car and starts to drive off.
So our photographer starts to chase Senator Hart's car.
He drives a couple blocks up, streets, down, streets, back and forth.
He gets out of the car, walks through a park, face, continues on.
Flipkey knows they're following him and they know,
he knows they're following ducks around the corner. They lose him for a second,
then they're running to catch up and then they turn a corner in an alley and
there's heart. There is the presumed nominee of the Democratic Party,
the most important democratic politician in the country.
And they're confronting each other. And for a moment,
standing in the alleyway behind hearts, townhouse,
they just stare at each other because there is no script for this moment.
Ultimately, he, he, he, he asked, well, who are you? Well,
we're from the Miami Herald and, um, he didn't really say anything.
So, uh, so I told him that we wanted to know why he was, uh,
meeting with this woman in his townhouse,
a woman who at that point we knew had spent the night with him.
He says in myriad ways, myriad times,
I'm not going to tell you who that woman was. This is private.
This isn't public. But he says there's no affair,
which he would maintain forever after.
And ultimately he said, I'm, I've said enough.
And he turned and walked inside and uh, slammed the door.
We did tell him though, he said, we're going to write this story. Uh,
unless we a, you give us a reason as to, uh, that,
that explains as to why what we are seeing and what we are concluding is wrong.
And he never did that. So we kind of look at ourselves and said, well,
now what do we do? Right?
Ultimately the call was, we have the proof we feel we needed.
We know that publicly.
He was saying these things and we now know that privately he was engaged in
this. So they ran back to the hotel room.
Fiedler frantically typed out the story. Gary Hart, Comma,
who's presidential campaign has been dogged by rumors of womanizing comma,
a spent Friday night and much of Saturday with a woman who came from Miami to
meet him.
I finally went back and I probably slept for three or four hours.
You're going to do the story.
The only thing that gives me pause is if you under this standard,
you'd lose Jack Kennedy. Certainly. Yeah. Lose a Woodrow Wilson.
I think so you'd lose a lot of people. Uh,
you might not want to lose, but you know,
you leap to the conclusion that the public would banish a person for that.
And I don't, I don't go there. So are you worried about how it's going to land?
That's everybody. So Jamie York terrified. I was just, I was terrified.
And the next morning, [inaudible] ABC news where the political world explodes.
Democratic presidential, hopeful. Gary Hart, Gary Hart, Gary Hart,
them yet truly became a firestorm. The Miami Herald reports today.
That heart quote spent Friday night and most of Saturday mind my hair old
reports that heart and a Miami woman spent Friday night alone together and in
his Washington townhouse with the young woman,
that story begins ricocheting around the country on the at m so by Sunday in
front of by Harold reporters last night, art denied any impropriety.
Hart denied any impropriety.
It's very apparent that not only is heart in trouble,
but the entire culture of media around politics has changed in some very
dramatic way.
[inaudible]
and when you think about the mindset of the television people, the radio people,
the newspaper people, is there any
self doubt there? Is there people saying, oh, should we,
is this really a question of his ability to conduct matters of state?
Is that question being asked? There's a tremendous amount of self doubt.
Not everyone agrees that such intense public scrutiny is necessary.
There was widespread feeling.
The Miami Herald was put on the defensive feeler and his colleagues had done was
wrong. You know, that's out of bounds. What business is it of the press?
You staked out a guy in his home, what are they up to?
Sneaking around in the bushes and all that.
A lot of reporters don't think it's relevant. And one reason is this,
nobody knows where this is going to lead this set of precedent.
Should reporters be sticking out? George Bushes House, Bruce Babbitt's house,
Joe Biden's house. But then in the same breath,
I mean there's generally this sense of, but you know,
all he had to do basically what? Stay clean. What was he thinking?
Heart is to blame.
It's Gary Hartsville and didn't he understand that things had changed and
doesn't the public maybe have a right to know?
And so the newspaper that began the controversy is not backing down.
This was not character assassination. This was character suicide. He did it.
We didn't even as the debate heats up over the ethics of its coverage of Gary
Hart,
so there was, there was a real conflict.
All the various echelon of media respond to this differently.
The New York Times refuses to touch it. Originally,
The Washington Post is deeply conflicted.
And as for the public and an unscientific Harold telephone, Paul,
63% of the callers said they thought the paper was making too much of a fuss
over Gary Hart.
I mean the polling shows that people think the media overstepped.
He's still pulling very strongly. He's winning in the public mind.
According to Leslie Stall, most people seem to be willing to compartmentalize.
Most people can split off. How's he going to be as president and you know,
is he cheating on his wife?
It was not clear that the tide was going to take hard out at all. So harden,
his team tried to get ahead of this story.
They schedule a press conference in New Hampshire and on the flight over,
Kevin Sweeney, his press secretary please least him.
I remember asking heart a question, something like,
have you ever been unfaithful to your wife? And he shot back at me with anger.
He said, I don't have to answer that question. That's a question that,
that I can answer to God, to my wife,
but it's not a question that I need to answer in politics.
That's a dangerous question to be asking. We don't want to go there.
And I just said, that's a great answer. Just hold that anger. That's,
that's an appropriate response.
Senator [inaudible] your heart please. We get to the press conference,
heartland Sweeney walk into this colonial style room at Dartmouth College.
[inaudible] a new poll. There are lights everywhere. The room is filled, sweaty,
it's hot.
There's more media than anyone's ever seen packed and it's a really intense
environment. [inaudible] at her heart.
Please send her to her heart has very little buffer and he's handling the
questions.
How are you going to convince them that you're not going to make this kind of
mistake and judgment about personal behavior? Again, really pretty brilliantly.
I won't tell them all, I'll demonstrate it as time goes on.
People are gonna want to know.
I want to give judgment your character on the issues that affect their lives and
their families, their nation. That's what this campaign is going to be about.
He's kind of firing on all cylinders and heart goes through, you know,
30 minutes, 40 minutes of questions.
And then you read in your remarks yesterday,
you raised the issue of morality and you raised the issue of truthfulness.
At some point he calls on a young reporter named Paul Taylor, very specific,
and I have a series of questions about it,
and Paul Taylor walks him through a series of questions.
You said you did nothing immoral.
Did you mean that you had no sexual relationship with Donna Rice last weekend or
any other times you believe that adultery,
yes. You've ever committed at all. He used to senator,
have you ever committed adultery? Senator Hart looked out
at the Sea of reporters. No.
No politician had ever publicly been asked that broad direct question about his
personal behavior. It really just, it shocked the room.
We don't know what Gary Hart was thinking in that moment.
He did not want to be interviewed on tape,
but it's clear that if he said yes or no to that broad of a question,
then his entire married life,
because have you ever committed adultery, that word ever?
His entire married life would suddenly be in plane. And as far as we know,
no other person in his situation in history had ever been asked to drag that
much of themselves into the limelight. And on his face,
you can see that he knows that this is never going to end. I mean, he,
he knew how many women he'd seen over the years.
He could envision them all being paraded through the papers.
He could tell already that there was all this new sort of cowboy press and that
the political press was following along,
that he was never going to be able to talk about his agenda and
hard stumbled around for a minute. And ultimately he says,
I doing nothing.
I don't have to answer that question. Was it produced by you? That's right.
This guy. That's right, Dan.
And I think when I heard that response coming upon it, I felt it.
I F I felt it. The tone was such that it felt like defeat.
It felt like he is exhausted and he can't take this. And I,
I was offended. I, uh,
I really in that moment thought this is just wrong.
This has nothing to do with, with what, what is necessary to run this country.
And I just thought, this is not this, this, this is not, we can,
we're not going to survive. And that moment affectively,
um, does him in [inaudible] I told you the facts. You don't believe me.
There's nothing I can do about it for a second. What are you
[inaudible]
Gary Heart is finished as a presidential candidate.
Gary Hart's formal campaign is only three weeks old.
There was simply no putting the genie back in the box.
Appearances yesterday where mobs aren't, has been
hammered to its knees asking the same questions again and again today after what
may be remembered as the most disastrous week any presidential candidates
endured in years. Heart told an aid, let's go home.
Couple of weeks later, that famous image,
if Gary Hart and Donna Rice comes out in the national enquirer. And uh,
that was that for people my age like that,
that image of Donna Rice sitting in his lap and he's got the shirt on that says
monkey business. That's, that's the thing you remember. Yeah. Now,
according to Matt, by,
you can look at this whole story in particularly Tom Fiedler taking that call
and Paul Taylor asking that question as this moment when all of these forces way
outside of Gary Hart's control come together, not just to sync his campaign,
but to change political journalism profoundly.
But as with all cultural shifts, there's more than one way to look at this.
So just for a gut check, we put the whole story.
We're talking about Tom Fiedler. Yeah. Front of this lady.
Can we have you introduce yourself? I'm Cokie Roberts would know who you are.
Like part two.
I have six grandchildren. No, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm a political commentator and author. Okay. Cokie Roberts believes that, yeah,
reporters were interested in character more after Watergate,
but it wasn't just that.
The thing that's important to keep in mind here is that there were many more
women covering candidates at that point than there had been before.
There were women on the bus, and in the case of Gary Hart,
several of those women had had personal encounters with him.
There were times when you'd be in a room where he had hit on every woman in the
room. So this was not somebody that, um,
women who recovering campaigns were ignorant of.
And the other thing to keep in mind, Robert,
is that they whole women's movement did talk quite a bit about the personal is
political and uh,
because the way women were treated was something that we thought and I continue
to think, um, is a good gauge of character.
And there was something of a sense that he treated women like Kleenex.
So, um,
we were expanding the universe of what was a major character flaw.
So then are you kind of, are you kind of rooting Fiedler on? Oh, absolutely.
Finally somebody who's written about it and [inaudible] and thank God it's a
guy, but as much as you were cheering them on,
was there any concern that that was changing the rules of journalism? No.
Why?
Because the rules of journalism were constantly changing as,
as they should. And according to Cokie Roberts,
this was less about journalism changing then about journalism,
catching up with the ethics of the time. Look,
we elect our presidents based who they are and not on what policies they stand
for. It's different from any other office.
The voters need to know as much as they can humanly know about that person.
So is there a line for you?
Is there a place you won't go in taking the full measure of a candidate?
I am not for president that I can think of. Hmm.
There's nothing you wouldn't touch? No.
I mean I'd have to know that it was true. Sure. But no, no,
I love that. Oh, Leslie stall had a slightly different take.
She's fabulous. Cokie Roberts. Um, I didn't go there.
That's interesting. I just didn't want it. I just didn't want to ask about it.
I didn't want to go there. [inaudible] excuse me. I'm telling you this,
even though I covered Watergate and would have asked any number of questions
about character, you know, it's open season fellows.
The public needs to know this, but you know,
sex is really a hard place for me to pry.
So I agree with it.
But I also have my own opinion that there's propriety and I'm old fashioned.
I guess am I, I don't know.
I've intended quite frankly to come down here this morning and read a short,
carefully worded political statement. This is Gary Hart statement.
A few days after that press conference saying that, uh,
I was withdrawing from the race and then quietly disappear from date
and then nothing were frankly tossing and turning all night. I said to myself,
hell no.
[inaudible]
I'm not going to do that because it's not my style.
And because I'm a proud man and I'm proud of what I've accomplished in public
life. Some things may be interesting,
but that doesn't necessarily mean they're important.
We're all going to have to seriously question the system for selecting our
national leaders. That reduces the press,
this nation to hunters and presidential candidates to being hunted politics in
this country. Take it from me.
It's on the Burj becoming another form of athletic competition or sporting
match. We all better do something to make this system work.
We're all going to be soon rephrasing Jefferson to say,
I tremble for my country when I think we may in fact get the kind of leaders we
deserve.
Now we did reach out to Mr Hartford comment explaining to him the story we were
doing and he wrote back this response.
Thank you for your letter and the invitation to participate in your current
story. Though I did not become president,
my life continues to be extraordinarily rich.
Perhaps someday someone will tell that story,
but for now I have no interest in revisiting what many consider a turning point
for the nation and a few an injustice. I do believe that the full,
an accurate story of that event remains to be told.
Signed Gary Hart.
[inaudible]
very special. Thanks to Jamie,
you work RJ York and to Joe Trippi and to met by you can find a link to Matt
Buy's book. All the truth is out that week.
Politics went tabloid on our website, radiolab.org.
This piece was produced by Simon Adler and uh,
I guess that's pretty much it. Next podcast,
we'll be exploring these issues in a totally different context.
I'm Jad Abumrad I'm Robert Krulwich and we approved this message.
[inaudible]
hi. Uh, this is Leslie stall. Okay, this is made-by. Uh,
I am reading the credits for the radio lab show on Gary Hart. Here we go.
Message one radio lab is produced by Jad Abumrad.
I'm going to do it again because I don't think I did. A bum, a bum, a bum Rad.
Our staff includes Simon Adler, Brenna Farrell, David Gable, Dylan, Keith,
Matt Kielty, Robert Krulwich, Andy Mills, Latif, Nasser, Kelsey Padgett,
Allien whack, Molly Webster, Soren Wheeler, and Jamie York.
It help from Alexandra Lee Young Abigail Kiel, Tracy haunt,
definitely Tam and Michael Lowinger are fact checkers or Eva Dasher and Michelle
Harris. Thanks guys. Your session can not be continued at this time.
Please try again later. Goodbye.